estoy seguro de que si os pidiera que
localizarais en un mapa o me dijerais
algo característico de países como
Colombia Venezuela Argentina o Brasil la
mayoría sabríais hacerlo sin embargo hay
otros países de América Latina que sin
saber bien porque suelen pasar casi
siempre completamente desapercibidos y
sabéis que ese es precisamente el caso
de nuestro protagonista de hoy Paraguay
Piénsalo bien Qué sabes de Paraguay
Seguro seguro que muchos de vosotros no
sabríais contestarme a esta pregunta y
sí Este es el primer vídeo
específicamente dedicado a Paraguay en
toda la historia de visualpolitik ya
tocaba El caso es que junto con su
vecina Bolivia Paraguay es el otro país
de América Latina sin salida al mar que
además se encuentra justo al lado de dos
de las potencias regionales Brasil y
Argentina y es cierto Paraguay no es tan
conocido como sus dos potencias vecinas
Pero esto no quita para que tenga
algunas características que Seguro
seguro nos llaman la atención todos por
ejemplo que sea el primer productor de
marihuana de toda Sudamérica es algo que
le pone inevitablemente en el radar
internacional y no sólo eso desde
Argentina muchas veces se ha acusado
Paraguay de ser Incluso un paraíso
fiscal por tener un impuesto de
sociedades y un IVA de solo el 10%, pero
seamos honestos desde luego si lo
comparamos con Argentina cualquier lugar
va a aparecer un paraíso fiscal
sea como sea el caso es que Paraguay en
2022 estuvo en el candelero no por los
impuestos ni por la marihuana sino por
esta Trágica noticia asesinado en
Colombia un fiscal anti mafia paraguayo
durante su luna de miel efectivamente
queridos amigos amigas el año pasado el
fiscal Marcelo petsi fue asesinado este
fiscal era una pieza clave del operativo
contra el narcotráfico conocido como a
ultranza Paraguay además había estado
colaborando con la DEA y la europol para
que os hagáis una idea había conseguido
Identificar y detectar a poderosos
empresarios y políticos tanto de
Paraguay como de algunos países de
Europa involucrados en el tráfico de
cocaína por desgracia apenas tres meses
después de llevar a cabo más de 100
redadas simultáneas y de incautar bienes
valorados en más de 100 millones de
dólares en mayo de 2022 fue asesinado en
frente de su mujer en la ciudad de
Cartagena Colombia Sí estas cosas siguen
pasando Más allá de Netflix ahora bien
no penséis que fue un hecho aislado Lo
cierto es que este caso Está muy unido a
los problemas endémicos que sufre
Paraguay pensarlo bien hablamos de uno
de los mayores productores de marihuana
del mundo y ahora también un punto
principal en la distribución de Coca no
pensáis que Pepsi estaba incomodando a
algunas personas pero ojo porque en un
país como Paraguay no estamos hablando
solo de narcos sino de algo mucho más
profundo queridos amigos amigas A qué
problemas se enfrenta exactamente
Paraguay Hasta qué punto podemos
considerarlos como algo internacional
podrá el nuevo presidente poner orden en
este vídeo te vamos a responder a estas
y otras preguntas pero antes antes vamos
a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la larga tradición política
uno podría llegar a pensar que la
historia moderna de Paraguay es como la
de cualquier otro país de América Latina
Es decir desde la independencia una
constante sucesión de periodos
democráticos y dictaduras de todo tipo y
en parte Así es pero Paraguay tiene una
particularidad Que prácticamente ninguno
de sus vecinos ha tenido salvo que
consideremos claro está a México como un
país vecino me estoy refiriendo al total
dominio político de un único partido la
asociación nacional republicana más
conocido como el partido Colorado y ojo
que hablamos de un dominio inexpugnable
[Música]
fundado en 1870 el partido Colorado no
llegó a tener un poder continuado hasta
que gobernó el país durante los 17 años
que medían entre 1887 y 1904 sin embargo
su máximo esplendor todavía tuvo que
esperar Algunos años Fue en 1954 con el
comienzo del brutal régimen del General
Alfredo stroessner apoyado Por cierto
por los Estados Unidos cuando el partido
Colorado comenzó su total hegemonía
política Al fin y al cabo Esto fue el
presidente de este partido durante toda
la dictadura sin embargo cuando en 1993
finalmente llegó la democracia a
diferencia de lo ocurrido muchos otros
países El dominio de este partido no
sufrió demasiados contratiempos
[Música]
y de hecho desde entonces la presidencia
de los Colorados sólo se vio perturbada
por la presidencia de Fernando Lugo y
muy temporalmente por la de Federico
Franco entre los años 2008 y 2013 no
obstante la presidencia de Lugo quedó
embarrada por la masacre de curuguaty
cuando 11 campesinos y seis policías
nacionales perdieron la vida en un
enfrentamiento para desalojar unas
tierras que llevaban más de un mes
ocupadas aunque no está del todo claro
lo que pasó realmente porque muchas
pruebas desaparecieron y Aparentemente
la policía no siguió las órdenes del
Ministerio del interior e incautar
solamente las armas a los campesinos
pero sea como sea la realidad es que
esto acabó con un juicio político que
expulsó a Lugo de la presidencia que
supuso un duro golpe para los candidatos
alternativos al partido Colorado quien
regresó al poder para no volver a soltar
en 2013 ganó Horacio cartes en 2018
Mario abdo Benítez y el último a finales
de abril de 2023 Santiago Peña todos
ellos por supuesto del partido Colorado
Santiago Peña un economista de 44 años
que ha trabajado para el fmi y el Banco
Central de Paraguay y que ya fue
ministro de hacienda en el pasado coge
las riendas de un país que desde
comienzos de siglo ha registrado un
fuerte crecimiento económico pero que
está duramente azotado por la pobreza el
narco y otros problemas endémicos
problemas a los que ahora Le tocará
enfrentarse ahora bien de qué estamos
hablando exactamente pues atentos
al servicio de las coimas
seguro que muchos ya os habéis dado
cuenta de que la situación del partido
Colorado se parece bastante a la que
tuvo el pri durante esos largos 70 años
que estuvo gobernando México sin
interrupción Y claro con tanto tiempo en
el poder sin ninguna alternancia creo
que todos sabemos Cuál fue el resultado
una corrupción galopante y el tráfico de
influencias convertido en toda una
prioridad para los políticos Pues bien
el caso de Paraguay no ha sido diferente
por eso no puede extrañarnos y a
principios de 2023 nos encontráramos con
esta noticia Estados Unidos hace una
vicepresidente y al ex presidente de
Paraguay por corrupción el expresidente
y el actual vicepresidente han estado
Implicados En un sistema de corrupción
que ha socavado las instituciones
democráticas de su país efectivamente
queridos amigos amigas de visualpolitik
tanto el expresidente Horacio cartes
como el actual vicepresidente Hugo
Velázquez han sido sancionados por el
gobierno de Estados Unidos por su
corrupción continuada por ejemplo cartes
que no deja de ser uno de los
empresarios más del país Aparentemente
le pagó a los miembros de su partido
10.000 dólares por cabeza para que
apoyaran su candidatura a presidente y
no sólo eso también se ha visto envuelto
en actividades de contrabando por
ejemplo pasando su propio tabaco
Argentina y Brasil emprendimiento en
estado y no solo eso es que además tanto
acartes como Velázquez se les ha acusado
incluso de aceptar sobornos del grupo
islamista libanés gesbolá Estados Unidos
considera un grupo terrorista por sus
vínculos con Irán sin embargo Estos no
son los únicos casos de corrupción a
gran escala que podemos encontrar en el
país
por ejemplo durante las primeras etapas
de la covid-19 el gobierno mandó a los
ciudadanos a comprar medicamentos que
amortiguaran los síntomas de la covid a
las farmacias privadas Cuál fue el
problema Pues que como ponía en las
cajas de los propios medicamentos estos
destinados a los hospitales públicos y
Qué significa todo esto Pues básicamente
que los medicamentos de los hospitales
fueron vendidos en el mercado negro de
tal forma que opagabas una barbaridad o
te quedabas Sin ellos algo que por
cierto desencadenó protestas masivas no
es para menos pensando bien Paraguay no
tiene las mejores condiciones económicas
del mundo vale Sí es cierto super
capitán ha crecido mucho desde los 1700
dólares en el año 2000 a los 5.900
actuales lo que evidentemente lo miremos
por donde lo miremos significa que
seguimos hablando de un país bastante
pobre con carácter general y de hecho su
idh su índice de desarrollo humano es el
más bajo de entre sus vecinos la
excepción de Bolivia y el número de
pobres sigue siendo muy elevado pero aún
más y si os dijera que la corrupción y
el tráfico de influencias están hasta
cierto punto normalizados en la sociedad
paraguaya pues fijaos
[Música]
en Paraguay el aprovecharse de la
posición de un amigo de un familiar o de
un conocido para mejorar la condición de
uno mismo tiene incluso su propia
palabra orecuete que procede de la
lengua guaraní desde luego suena
bastante mejor que tráfico de
influencias pero no solo la ética de
lorecuete está aceptada Es que la
corrupción también es parte fundamental
del día a día de la sociedad paraguaya
es cierto No es una corrupción enorme
que mueva a millones a gran escala pero
las coimas los pequeños sobornos están a
la orden del día sobre todo si hablamos
de agilizar trámites administrativos
ya lo veis la corrupción Campa a sus
anchas en Paraguay mientras el 25% de
las 7 millones de personas del país es
decir unos 2 millones siguen viviendo en
la pobreza y para muchos analistas esta
pobreza es la causa de otro de los
graves problemas del país os imagináis
cuál puede ser veámoslo
la triple frontera
[Música]
a lo largo de los años os hemos contado
aquí en visualpolitik muchos casos en
los que debido a la Pobreza la gente se
ha terminado zambullendo en el mundo del
crimen para mejorar su posición ya sea
en México con los narcos o en Nigeria
con los grupos que roban petróleo entre
otros ejemplos Pues bien según muchos
analistas este es también el caso de
Paraguay sin embargo no todos están de
acuerdo para algunos es la ausencia del
estado y la falta de medios lo que ha
hecho quien Paraguay el crimen
organizado se haya convertido en una
próspera industria por ejemplo el
ejército popular paraguayo que es una
organización guerrillera que nació en
2008 con una ideología marxista
leninista ha sido y sigue siendo
ampliamente apoyado por algunos
campesinos que se sienten abandonados
por el estado no obstante Aunque este
grupo guerrillero sea una preocupación
constante para el gobierno no es ni de
lejos el mayor de sus problemas para eso
tenemos que irnos hasta la llamada
triple frontera
en la triple frontera confluyen las
fronteras entre Paraguay y Brasil y la
Argentina que están divididas por el río
Paraná Pues bien este punto está
considerado como uno de los más
calientes de todo el mundo en términos
de criminalidad
La debilidad o incluso ausencia de
mecanismos y funcionarios en la frontera
capaz de agilizar el comercio
transfronterizo entre los tres países ha
hecho que los grupos del crimen
organizado internacional encuentren en
la triple frontera un espacio
relativamente cómodo donde poder operar
hablamos de un espacio donde se han
llegado a detectar operaciones de grupos
criminales como el taiwanés bambú Unido
La Mafia rusa o incluso la yakuza
japonesa por supuesto ninguno de ellos
tiene tanta presencia ni poder en la
triple frontera y Paraguay como el
brasileño primer Comando de la capital
el pcc es este grupo que controla las
rutas del narcotráfico entre Brasil
Bolivia y Paraguay y os estaréis
preguntando Cómo puede darse semejante
concentración de bandas y grupos del
crimen organizado Pues por una simple
razón la falta de medios de control
de esta forma Mientras que el comercio
legal sufre todo tipo de restricciones
las que usan los narcos para atravesar
el río Paraná y llegar al río iguazú
para ir a Brasil por ejemplo lo hacen
muchas veces sin tener que parar para
ser registrados por falta de medios y
tres cuartas partes de lo mismo pasa con
los camiones de los comerciantes que
cruzan desde Paraguay a Brasil por el
puente de la amistad en este caso además
es habitual que usen dobles fondos en
los camiones que transportan madera y
soja pero no solo eso incluso los
aviones que llegan cargados de cocaína
desde Bolivia a Paraguay y que aterrizan
en pistas de vuelo clandestinas no son
detectados por la falta de radares Sin
embargo a pesar de que la falta de
medios de control por parte del Estado
sea más que evidente ese puede no ser el
único problema me explico muchos
analistas se preguntan si estos grupos
no están actuando con total impunidad es
decir que detrás de todo volvería a
estar la generalizada corrupción del
sector público la corrupción hace
posible negociar de manera particular el
cumplimiento de la Norma con el fin de
evadir su cumplimiento la consecuencia
directa es la impunidad y con ella se
pretende evitar por parte de estas redes
una detención un juicio o ir a la cárcel
Sonia Alda mejías doctora en historia
por la Universidad Autónoma de Madrid e
investigadora del Real instituto Elcano
no obstante Paraguay no solo es una
especie de simbiosis entre el mundo
criminal y la corrupción Paraguay
también tiene una característica que lo
hace especialmente relevante en la
geopolítica mundial pero esta mucha pero
que mucha atención
[Música]
un club cada vez más limitado
si sois fieles seguidores de
visualpolitik seguro que ya sabéis que
no quedan demasiados países que
reconozcan a la República de China es
decir a Taiwán como la auténtica china
hablamos esencialmente de algunas
pequeñas Islas nación en Oceanía como
nauru o las Islas Marshall la ciudad del
Vaticano en Europa o la antigua
sofilandia en África que siguen
manteniendo este reconocimiento un
reconocimiento que es precisamente en
Latinoamérica donde más peso tiene es
cierto la mayoría son pequeñas Islas
caribeñas como Santa Lucía pero por
ejemplo Guatemala Belice y Haití siguen
reconociéndote a Taiwán como la
auténtica China y sabréis decirme qué
otro país hace lo propio 3 2 1 Exacto
hablamos de Paraguay y de hecho aunque
no sea el más poblado de todos ellos sí
es el más grande y os preguntaréis Cómo
es que Paraguay no ha reconocido ya a la
República popular china como han hecho
la inmensa mayoría de sus países vecinos
Pues básicamente podríamos resumirlo en
que Paraguay es un amigo muy fiel
Y es que veréis desde que la Paraguay
del General stroessner reconociera a la
Taiwán de chanca y sech por los valores
anticomunistas que ambos países
compartían Paraguay se ha visto
ampliamente beneficiado por su amistad
con el país asiático ya sea con apoyo
militar entrenando a soldados mandando
armamento o con becas de estudios
universitarios a jóvenes paraguayos para
que estos puedan estudiar en Taiwán El
pequeño país asiático ha hecho gala de
su diplomacia económica para mantener su
relación con el país más grande en
reconocerlo de hecho la sede del
congreso paraguayo inaugurada en 2003
fue construida en parte con una ayuda de
20 millones de dólares que da igual le
dio además el partido Colorado también
pertenece a la liga mundial por la
libertad y la democracia antigua liga
anticomunista mundial que se fundó en
Taiwán en 1966 Y no sólo eso la cercanía
de Paraguay a Taiwán ha supuesto también
que sobre todo desde la administración
Trump las relaciones con Estados Unidos
se hayan fortalecido no obstante no
penséis que esta amistad agrada a todos
hay muchos que ven en esta relación una
oportunidad perdida de ganar más dinero
si se reconociera a la República popular
China y bueno algo de razón quizás no
les falta
[Música]
De hecho son muchos los empresarios y
políticos paraguayos que consideran que
si se reconociera al régimen de shijing
se podría lograr que la balanza
comercial del país fuera positiva un
ejemplo de este descontento es la
asociación paraguaya de productores y
exportadores de carne que se ha quejado
numerosas veces de las cuotas de
importación a la carne que impone Taiwán
un problema que el país de chancay
seccionó en 2020 cuando eliminó esas
cuotas y permitió la entrada de carne
paraguaya prácticamente sin
restricciones de esta manera el gobierno
paraguayo consiguió que sus ganaderos no
sintieran que se estaban quedando atrás
en comparación con Argentina Brasil o
Uruguay países que sí tienen un enorme
comercio con china no obstante son estos
tres países los que quizás mayor
frustración sienten con esta decisión de
Paraguay
veréis Paraguay junto con Argentina
Brasil y Uruguay forman el común del sur
comúnmente llamado mercosur y Qué es el
mercosur pues muy simple es un mercado
común donde los productos y las personas
de los cuatro países se puede mover más
o menos libremente entre ellos y no sólo
eso además los tratados de libre
comercio con otros países que no forman
parte del mercosur son negociados
conjuntamente y qué quiere decir esto
Pues que si los cuatro miembros no votan
a favor de cerrar un acuerdo comercial
con un país concreto simplemente este no
se puede llevar a cabo seguro que lo
sabéis por dónde van las quejas de Los
Socios del mercosur efectivamente
queridos amigos tanto Brasil como
Argentina y Uruguay quieren cerrar un
acuerdo de libre comercio con china cuál
es el problema que Paraguay no vota a
favor porque reconoce a Taiwán y no a
China y si no vota a favor pues no se
cierra de acuerdo por eso desde la
presidencia de Fernando Lugo en 2008 e
incluso con la de abdo Benítez se ha
barajado la opción de cambiar de una vez
por todas a Taiwán por china Pero al
final
ninguno se ha atrevido a dar el paso y
Santiago Peña ya ha dejado totalmente
Claro que su socio preferente va a
seguir siendo Taiwán Paraguay tiene una
relación histórica con Taiwán y esta
relación no se puede cuantificar
simplemente en términos económicos hay
algo más que el comercio el comercio es
importante nosotros necesitamos generar
progreso Pero también tenemos que
entender que las relaciones tienen que
basarse en valores democráticos Santiago
Peña presidente electo de Paraguay 2023
querida comunidad de visualpolitik ya lo
veis los retos que le esperan a Santiago
Peña no son moco de pavo aparte de la
pobreza en el país el constante aumento
del crimen organizado y la corrupción
endémica van a ser asuntos prioritarios
sin embargo al igual que muchos esperan
no ver cambios en cuanto a la posición
de Paraguay frente a Taiwán también se
duda mucho de que Peña vaya a atacar la
corrupción del país Al fin y al cabo el
expresidente Horacio Cortés el mismo que
ha sido sancionado por Estados Unidos
por su corrupción es su mentor político
y muchos ya se vuelen que va a
protegerlo a toda Costa Pero la pregunta
ahora es para ti crees que Santiago Peña
conseguirá hacer de Paraguay un país más
transparente Cuál crees que es la mejor
manera de afrontar el crimen organizado
de la triple frontera sucumbirá
finalmente Paraguay al atractivo mercado
chino o por el contrario seguirá siendo
fiel a su vieja amiga Taiwán como
siempre no olvides que aquí en
visualpoli tik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscríbete a
este canal si es que aún no lo has hecho
y dale a la campanita Para no perderte
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle al botón de like un
saludo y hasta la próxima